hey everyone it's my vatos and welcome
to the overflows market analysis for
Tuesday September 5th 2017 interesting
day in the market so I think I'm not
gonna get into a lot of stuff that
happened I'm just gonna talk a bit about
the order flow in in the Aussie dollar
act there were some great examples today
of Delta analysis in the order flow in
the Aussie dollar but first a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision future strain
contains substantial risk and it's not
for every investor and investor could
potentially lose all are more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost not jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
training and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance it's not necessarily
indicative of future results tools I use
in this presentation are the same tools
I use in all the presentations order
flows trader which is the volume
footprint chart and the Delta scalper
now there's a lot of footprint charts
available nowadays and again you know do
you want just the basic footprint chart
or do you want one that's got you know
more information for you and Delta
scalper is a tool that analyzes the
order flow Delta Delta is the net
aggressive mind versus a net aggressive
selling so yeah again you know Aussie
dollar not many people you really trade
the Aussie dollar you know most people
are sort of fixated around the jab the
euro currency predominantly then you
know the JP and British Pound are the
euro zone's it's you know even the
crosses the yen versus the yen vs. Swiss
and Bazzi dollar you know is a good
market you know it trends it trends
nicely and I'm going to show you a
couple of moves from your high down to
your low back and then you know off your
low back up but you know just going back
here so you got this nice move this
morning Monday markets going higher
higher higher new highs new highs nice
positive Delta's on these highs you know
300 every two years 300 to 600 start
getting up here the highs here 155 120
925 you come up here first time you hit
this high you had a divergence you got
negative Delta 50 for the bar right in
front of it you got a strong positive
Delta 10 for
then you got a small Delta here negative
it's minus 56 and 16949 and in this bar
you got 256 but let's analyze this these
numbers you're looking at you know what
you got going up in here just take it
back here from this high positive Delta
positive Delta positive Delta this one
max Delta 406 max Delta 289 min Delta is
quite small 0 and minus 2 so at no point
in these bars were there net aggressive
selling this bar early in the bar there
was net aggressive son it was minus 2 1
6 but it settled up at 25 positive 25 so
later in the bar the buying came back in
okay that that's a bullish sign and then
this bar very bullish positive Delta of
1040 small negative small min Delta so
at one point it was minus 117 nothing
major but you know 1/4 minus 1 17 to
positive 10 40 which is you know ended
up on your max Delta is a bullish sign
in the Delta then you get up here vine
continues you got max Delta of 547 so
you know at one point in this bar you
had net aggressive buyers 547 versus
whatever was in that part and when this
bar turned around ended up at minus 56
so you went from positive 547 to ending
up at minus 56 so it's a swing of 600
lots in aggressive buying to aggressive
selling cuz you know it was plus 547
ended up at minus 56 so went from
obviously from 547 down to you know zero
down to negative 56 so that's about 600
that's a bearish sign honestly then what
happens next bar market starts trading
lower comes back up takes out the high
by one tick one tick only okay and then
next bar you got the Delta a scalper
kicking in you got negative Delta 256
but look at the spar on this high okay
you know it's kind of mixed Delta's 49
if you analyze the max Delta versus the
min Delta it's 272 min Delta's minus 68
so the others bars actually it's kind of
mixed I'm not saying oh you know we had
272 we end up at 49 it gave it back no
this bar here this one is more telling
then this one honest I was looking for
the self to come here but then the next
bar here not the scalper kicks in you
got negative Delta 256 at no point was
it max Delta ever it was all min Delta
all negative Delta in the sand bar the
whole time so no point where they're
aggressive buyers taking control of the
bar
you don't just because you have zero
Delta doesn't mean no there was no
aggressive buyers yes there were I mean
obviously you had stuff trading on the
on the upper side is aggressive mine but
it wasn't strong enough to turn the bar
positive Delta and then what happens we
sell off from this high you know just go
lower - 700 Delta you know again it's
it's right near your min Delta number
739 and 704 next bar negative Delta and
X bar negative Delta then you come down
in here to the not the low of the day
but it's a nice swing low and what do
you got early in this bar - for 58 you
end up the bar at Delta of 1 again is it
could have been 0 could have been + 2
could be minus 1 the number exactly
lands on sometimes it's a bit random so
don't don't read anything into its as
well it was it ended up at 1 that means
something no it's a bit random whether
it ends up at 1 0 it's all dependent on
the volume in the bar right so you know
you see sometimes the Delta is 0 don't
get all excited say all ended up at 0
that means something not really it just
just means it ended up at 0 then so this
bar here right - for 58 it was very
negative and what happened the buying
came in vine came in to turn it to you
know positive even if this was minus 8 I
would still like this bar next bar Delta
scalper kicks in a buy this time you
know earlier yet up here at that high
you had to sell - 63 in this bar at one
point nothing major but it ended up
right on your max Delta 577 you got the
you know you got the signal there to buy
and what happens is the market rallies
up going into the clothes where are we
right now you know we had some aussie
data come out here that's why it's mark
it's a little bit lower but really you
know the signal now was you know off
okay so you can analyze in the delta up
in here this one was bearish it just
ticked up here made a new high by a tick
at
you got to sell-off you know if you're
using a stop right above the high you're
yeah it gets topped out and just
19 Lots before the sell-off comes but
again if using the Delta scalper it
analyzes all that Delta in there for you
gives you that nice sell signal get down
here again Delta scalper analyzing the
Delta for you over these bars you know
on this move down telling you get ready
to buy and you got a nice move up you
know wasn't move all the way back up to
the highs of the day I mean the market
closed then you went into the asian
session and but again it's it's Delta
scalper analyzes all that stuff like
what I just went through for you that's
what the Delta scalper does for you okay
you can do that yourself or you can just
pick up the Delta scalper and it'll do
it for you so again yeah I'm trying not
to keep these videos too long so this is
about seven minutes so again thanks for
watching this and you know Delta is is a
tool you know that's available with the
order flow I mean not necessarily you
don't need to buy Mike my software to
use Delta you know you could have any
footprint charge should have Delta and
if it doesn't then change your software
you know there's there's other
software's out there you said you don't
have to buy mine if you're ready using
an order flow software you can use you
know this type of analysis in your
trading you know what I like you to buy
my software yeah of course of course I
would you know but again you know if you
already have software I know some people
spend thousands and thousands of dollar
dollars for software that basically does
does the same thing my software does for
a lot less again we have a trading is
it's a thinking man's game you should
think about what what you're seeing
happening in the market and make your
own decisions based off that or again
you know maybe you're new to order flow
and you might want to pick up the deltas
copper by itself and you know understand
the markets you know as your
understanding order flow at least you
got the deltas scalp or giving you the
signs and hopefully you can start to
pick it up over time that you don't need
to rely on Delta scalper because you
know you could you could look at any
market you know with with order foil it
trades decent size and yeah and you can
understand what's going on and that's
what you want to do as a trader you
don't want to be relying on indicators
all the time saying oh what am I
supposed to do my supposed to buyer so
here no you should be able to
look at the market confidently say this
is a great buying opportunity or this is
a great selling opportunity and take the
trade all right that's what trading is
it's not about following signs you know
just really quick okay I'm trying to
keep these short but you know you start
talking and then I get a bit excited
about what's going on in the market so
this is soybeans right and look okay I
try hi the day Delta this is the Delta
surge Delta surges is a free indicator
go to a website you can download it for
free
this is the Delta surgery analyzes the
Delta as this mark is moving up it
starts changing you got a delta surge
cell here right up at the hi this is 972
what do we do is sell off five cents
down to 1967 you start rallying up again
before you turn around and start heading
back down south then you get down here
there's a very bullish sign in the order
flow you got racial balance low this
ratio you got point of control right on
the low next bar you got the Delta
scalper kicking in as well so again
you're getting this by from 964 what do
we do we trade all the way up to 960 you
know seven this area where you got Delta
scalper gives you a sell so again you
know that's a nice three four point move
right there the cell doesn't work out
again but this at this time you're
closing in about 10 minutes here so
you'd want to be careful taking a trade
you know going right going into the
close you know this one was a bit
earlier this was you know over an hour
going into the close or is this one is
just minutes going into the close so you
know I don't know if you'd want to be
taking that if you took this you know
this one would stopped you out
unfortunately but you're having a few
nice trades in here with with Delta in
the order flow I mean you know I can get
one I could create a an hour long video
this is the Delta surge giving you a buy
here actually so you know I only showed
you this one but you go back a little
bit earlier Delta surge which you can
download for free on the website it's
available for free it's a delta tool
again from nine or set nine sixty nine
and a half all the way up to the next
into the cell nine seventy two so it's
three cents that's a three cents in the
beans is you know three points in the
SPS that's a buck fifty then you get the
sell here it's another five cents so
it's eight cents already you know
eight census is 400 bucks on a one lot
you know do the math so anyway um I
don't want Pope another chart otherwise
I'll talk another ten minutes so I wait
thanks for watching this and have a
great day and hopefully I'll try and get
another one up for you tomorrow the room
is closed the training rooms closed this
week I've got a lot of stuff to catch up
on
in terms of programming we're trying to
get our indicators compatible with shark
indicators for you guys out there that
use bloodhound and Blackbird and you
know what kind of excited about that so
I've got to do some footwork on that as
well so have a great day and hopefully
I'll try to get a video up for you
tomorrow
thanks bye bye